d may still be out today but this
morning thousands of nevada college
students head back to the classroom for
a new semester so despite the surge in
omicron coronavirus cases unlv nevada
state college csn they're going back to
in-person learning today hector mejia
live this morning at the csn charleston
campus hector what are staff doing to
make sure everyone stays safe
well a large number of csn students are
already starting off the semester
remotely over 50 percent of classes
offered at csn are fully online and here
this morning it's pretty quiet here on
campus csn says that it's currently
doing a major renovation to its air
filtration system at all three campuses
are also offering testing and
vaccinations on site the college says it
is ready to pivot if needed 65 covid
cases reported last week and that's up
from 47 cases the week before we've
learned the southern nevada health
district has been on the ground at all
three campuses providing free cova
testing vaccinations and boosters as
students try to stay safe they also face
the reality that at the end of the day
certain classes must be in person
science is a great example it's very
difficult to learn anatomy and
physiology or microbiology if you're
doing that in the remote environment we
have had tools to do that but the
learning is much more comprehensive in
person
we did ask csn about the threshold that
would prompt the cancellation of all
in-person classes we are told there's a
protocol in place and that the decision
is made by faculty the vp of academic
affairs and a covet officer so the
testing vaccinations and boosters
offered at the csn campuses again are
being offered by the southern nevada
health district you can make an
appointment on their website reporting
live hector mejia live local now